SANDI FURNESS:
Hey, thanks for coming.
FRANK VERNON:
Can we sign off on this?
SANDI: He wants veto rights
over any Roy family member
ever taking over as CEO.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
What's so great
about this episode
is that it's all
on borrowed time.
All that deal making,
it should have happened
two weeks ago.
Do you mind if we take a beat?
STEWY HOSSEINI: Yeah,
you have tons of time.
And it's like, "Yes. Anything
that makes the deal work.
Let's please just sign here
and we'll work everything out
later."
(WHISPERING) There's
nothing to discuss. If--
Right, but it's
basically optics.
I don't think
Gerri's plotting against them.
They don't seem
to have the job anyway.
Everyone but them seem to know
what fuck ups they are.
With all due respect, Gerri,
get bent.
And then, she picks up on
Roman's being sort of hurt
by that.
-Sorry about--
-ROMAN ROY: Oh, about what?
Trying to fuck me over
to consolidate your position?
And I think she does try
to walk it back a little bit.
-Hey, pa. Got a minute?
-Later.
Connor, he has some leverage
and so often in his life,
in that family,
he hasn't had any leverage.
I wanted to ask you
for a really significant role
to burnish my reputation.
ALAN RUCK:
I've seen from watching
my brothers and sister,
the only way to get ahead
in this family and this company
is to play dirty.
You were never interested.
I don't do ancient history.
CONNOR ROY: I don't wanna get
into ancient history either.
So, if I have some shit
on what he did with my mother,
yeah, I might call
a press conference.
JESSE ARMSTRONG: Logan's weak...
I need a piss.
You wanna make a decision now...
before?
...so the kids have to choose
whether to use
that moment of weakness
to further their own positions.
SHIV ROY: Okay.
I think we go back
to Sandi and Stewy
and try and save the deal.
ROMAN: No, no. We can't
because Dad said no deal--
No, Dad didn't say shit, Rome.
No, he didn't.
His urethra had wrestled control
from his brain.
Shiv knows that she can get this
across the line in this moment.
Hey! Uh, I was wondering
if we could have another chat,
just the two of us,
before the vote closes.
Shiv has that choice
and she makes a move.
What's goin' on?
How about a fourth seat
on the board for you?
And there's
a positioning element to her
that will maximize
her personal benefit
in whatever scenario she's in.
And Waystar, for balance,
will need an extra one for me.
I see.
I've got the White House
on the line. It's the president.
JESSE: Like all the good things
in this show,
this came out of
a debate, discussion
about who would take that call.
I mean, if anyone here
is bootleg Logan, it'd be Roman.
Gerri does think
that might be disarming
for Roman to get on the phone.
SPEAKER:
Are you kidding? Are you sure?
I think there's also part
of Gerri that's like, "You go."
But that's not
to endanger Roman.
That's just a gut instinct
of saving her own hide
(CHUCKLES) at any cost.
Uh, how ya doin'?
There has been a good amount
of evolution for Roman
in terms of, at the beginning,
I don't think
he really understood
what his job was,
but he thought,
"Fake it 'til you make it."
I think that you are a really
significant historical figure.
KIERAN CULKIN: And right now,
he's feeling confident
and it's a little bit odd.
Like, "Is this it?
Is this all my job is?
I can do this.
I think I'm doing it.
I can even talk to
the president. I'm pretty good."
(CHUCKLES)
SHIV: Congratulations.
You did it.
I need to see all the details.
The biggest disappointment,
I think, is with Shiv.
We couldn't risk a vote.
She is, ostensibly,
his favorite,
but she's constantly
trying to prove something.
JESSE:
For all these kids, it's easy
to be their father's emissary
and he has a double-edged
attitude to their independence.
-SHIV: What would you have done,
then?
-LOGAN ROY: Not that.
He just doesn't like not being
the center of attention.
Exactly. He doesn't like
not being the one
who made it happen.
What would you have done?
I'd have figured it out.
They are his children
and he wants them to succeed,
but he doesn't want to say,
"This is the lesson.
You should be doing this."
He wants them to find out.
(YELLING) Stop buzzing
in my fucking ear!
He's certainly a disciplinarian,
but he's not always
a great instructor.
Your dad wants a word.
-Yeah, let's go.
-Okay.
These people have grown up
in a way that has
inflicted damage on them.
BRIAN COX: You could say,
"If it wasn't for my dad,
I would've been this."
I understand that,
but it's an excuse.
You have to own who you are.
We are abused,
and hurt people hurt people.
LOGAN ROY:
Block this number for me.
You sure?
Permanently.